a pesar de las versiones contradictorias
llegó a Hiroshima tras arribar en un
avión oficial francés el mandatario
ucraniano se trasladó a la sede de la
Cumbre del g7 en medio de un fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad
su objetivo fundamental sumar el mayor
respaldo posible que les ayude a repeler
la invasión rusa algunos de los
protagonistas de la reunión se
encontraron con el mandatario entre
ellos dos de sus principales aliados el
Primer Ministro británico y el canciller
Alemán olafones
también sostuvo un encuentro con el
Primer Ministro indio un comprador
importante de petróleo ruso a pesar de
las sanciones y con el presidente
francés Emmanuel macron se tocó un tema
clave para la defensa ucraniana la
entrega de aviones de combate hablamos
mucho sobre la futura coalición de jets
quiero agradecerles a ustedes y a todos
los socios por la decisión sobre las
misiones de entrenamiento
para nosotros es muy importante
involucrar esta fórmula a tantos como
sea posible y estoy feliz de que haya
señales muy positivas
escucharemos sobre eso pero sí creo que
puede cambiar las reglas del juego en
declaración conjunta el grupo de los
siete condenó la invasión rusa al tiempo
que se comprometió a brindar el apoyo
necesario en el campo militar financiero
humanitario militar y diplomático en
este último aspecto llamaron a China a
mediar para el fin de la guerra y el
retiro inmediato de las fuerzas
invasoras